hello sluggy wuggies i'm so excited that
we have this liquid iv you guys can grab
your liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code trash tuesday
that's 25 off your order when you shop
using promo code trash tuesday at
liquidive.com you guys we love athletic
greens with one delicious scoop of
athletic greens you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole food
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
tuesday again that is
athleticgreens.com take ownership over
your health and pick up the ultimate
daily nutritional insurance
let's talk about liquid death it is our
favorite drink here on this show right
now i have bury it alive
i have the severed lime in my favorite
green mango chainsaw gold because
obviously and we say death to plastic
and we love drinking water out of our
tall boy cans because why not and you
guys can get free shipping on all water
and merch at liquid death dot com slash
trash that's liquid death dot com slash
trash or find liquid death at 711 target
albertson safeway or amazon
hi slugs i'm doing stand up on the road
and you can see me in dc austin and i
think elsewhere i added some dates
seattle i don't remember but
esteronice.com for tickets
i can't wait to see on the road it's
been so amazing i just love meeting you
guys you can come see me this weekend
july 29th in austin texas at the vulcan
gas company there's just one night there
so get your tickets before they sell out
springfield missouri the blue room
comedy club i'll be there august 12th
through 13th
homestead pennsylvania i'll be at the
pittsburgh improv i'll be in tempe
arizona i'm going to be at the caluso
california casino it's going to be so
fun that's one night only two those are
all in september then you can see me
later on in the year in kansas city
irvine california san jose michigan and
florida and a lot more dates coming so
go to andyletterman.com
[Music]
oh jlo and ben and ben got married this
this
this whole thing it's so embarrassing do
you remember when we were in palm
springs and i said i think she just
was like lustful for him again and the
sex must have been good this is not
gonna last this is like her just you
know reclaiming the good sex they once
had yeah it turns out there's love
i
how is it not for publicity i'm so sorry
explain how is it not because they
jlo has been in the spotlight
non-stop
like for the last i feel like two years
right i almost
feel like
hustlers oscar camp i obviously just
watched the documentary like that didn't
work out and so it's like she's going
back to her roots she's like i'm gonna
have a bunch of marriages i'm gonna go
back to ben
i don't know i i don't know either
because i did read that letter she sent
out in her newsletter and i'm sure
someone i'm not sure if she wrote it
herself and she signed jennifer lynn
affleck
i know
and um i you know maybe when you're in
your 50s you just
there's clarity and maybe you just are
like i'm not wasting any time i'm an
affleck now
an affleck yeah jennifer affleck
i'm i'm not ready
he's a lopez
he should have been
yes he should have been a lopez ben
lopez he likes latin girls really yeah
because he dated that spanish actress
yeah
um
i every other girl on riot i know okay
wait i randomly got
ben
i randomly got hit with this thought
do i rebrand i don't even need to get
married but do i rebrand as esther king
is povitskiy holding me back do i become
esther king wow
it is such a strong name it's a rebrand
carl like it's not a rebrand it's called
marriage
you're rebranding marriage that's what
you're doing
carlos you've known me the longest what
do you think about
i think um it's a strong name but i'm
afraid that we're getting into
old-fashioned anti-semitic hollywood
names what do you mean like if you're
trying to get rid of your more jewish
name maybe we're getting into some
old-fashioned hollywood stuff no but
it's not even like a
that my name is jewish it's like first
of all the name esther king somehow
sounds more jewish but to me it's
i don't know i'm like just
it came to me maybe maybe we do it maybe
add a kong at the end okay
all right i'll consider that
i think it's the one syllable last name
is fairy like movie star um
you're making me want it biel confirmed
she would change it to timberlake but
i've never heard now it's not the time
nate
because you know justin timberlake is
going through um
i don't know
people are turning their backs on him
really i don't fully grasp why yet i
understand it but i don't know why we're
doing it i think he's going straight
into tube territory that's number one
number two um people are starting to
realize that he might have
single-handedly like derailed janet
jackson's career
um oh yeah even though i mean that can't
you can't single-handedly derail
someone's career in that way but that
was a time when you know a nip slip
could have destroyed somebody well also
there was those old clips of him talking
about brittany that i feel like didn't
yeah seem good i don't remember the
specifics but it was he seemed like a
jerk him on like uh letterman i think
yeah like he was also a
dumb boy at that time right he doesn't
excuse it but he was dumb and also like
again i don't want to defend him because
i'm not like i'm team brittany forever
but
devil's advocate is like
that is how the culture was
and yes it would have been nice if he
would have like stepped in and stood up
for brittany
but
dude i was watching an old elvis
interview and they [ __ ] asked him he
was at this big like um press conference
promoting a tour or no his show at
madison square garden i've become
reinvigorated in my elvis obsession but
they asked him what is your thought on
the women's movement and feminism and he
said i don't really want to comment on
like political stuff i'm just an
entertainer and it does feel really
outdated like it's just crazy to see
someone
not comment on like
women being equals
well he's also somebody who said as soon
as he saw
the birth of his child he no longer
wanted to
engage with his partner sexually he did
yeah
like he was like
that's a thing
for elvis yes
he has choices yeah yeah wait carlos
will you look up the madonna [ __ ]
complex because i'm pretty sure that's
what this is yes it is oh it is okay
yeah as soon as you see um that woman as
a mother
you lose sight of the lover
i okay
i don't understand this because isn't it
like hot that a woman
is the mother of your kid carlos peace
i've never i i understand what you're
saying i don't think anyone's ever said
that in pop culture though what like oh
giving birth is so hot now i'm turned on
for life i think you're thinking of like
oh i have love for my wife now i feel
like we have a friend that is has this
disease no it happened to me and bobby
madonna [ __ ] complex we're the perfect
example of this why because i became
mama
and he became baby
and i mean what's the problem i'm turned
on
yeah i'm kind of into it now mama it
becomes a problem when you wake up and
there's a [ __ ] adult 50 year old man
like latched on to your nipples in a
non-sexual way carlos
yeah i i still understand where he's
coming from though
just in that moment and where he's
i feel like i understand bobby being
like turned on and thinking you're the
caretaker being like mama
loves but she's saying that he's not yet
he didn't it didn't work that's i think
that's part of the reason why um amongst
several other things but yeah i think
that me being like the responsible
figure in the house like you know got
his dick soft
i wasn't this like when we first met i
was a little bit more rebellious a
little bit more mysterious like he
couldn't always get a you know so i when
i became this like susie like homemaker
i started being like somebody that he
could really rely on i think his dick
got soft for me that is a common thing i
just of course saw tick tock that was
this it was i wish i had sent it to one
of you guys it was this woman who
literally laid out every detail of what
she does to take care of her man and it
was like
it was like like petting him to sleep
like awakening him with a fresh coffee
dream come true
let's let's editorialize later
let's just stick to the facts but she
was completely caregiving babying him
every little step and then and it had so
many views and i always look at the
comments like what does everyone else
think and there's a lot of comments like
a submissive woman like this is like
that's who gets cheated on
and
i'm wondering if there's if it's a kind
of the same thing that you're talking
about it's like when you become
when you let someone walk all over you
it's like you might think you're doing
the right thing but somehow that is just
not hot anymore i don't know
i think everyone gets cheated on whether
you are
um the submissive woman whether you are
in between whether you're the dominant
it doesn't matter someone
there's so many different cracks that
can happen in a relationship to justify
someone feeling like all right like i
gotta step out on this
you know relationship i gotta do this i
gotta do that
um
so i don't know i i don't know i could
never see myself um being completely
submissive i am
submissive in the sense that like i like
to do like the traditional
female roles of like the 1950s i do like
to cook i do like to take care of
somebody i do like to make sure that
their day is a little bit easier but i
don't that's so hot i don't nod and say
like yes to everything they say i do put
my foot down and i do
also um ask for my needs to be met this
is so hot everything about what you just
described i'm like
take me
it's just too real sometimes
[Laughter]
jose from dance moms is a perfect
example of why you should wear your hair
up super tight in this photo you can see
her hairline change after four years
from 2014 all the way to 2018. in 2014
is when she started dancing
competitively and she started wearing a
high pony because she tied her hair up
every day for dance there was too much
stress on her hairline and because of
that it caused hair loss by 2018 her
hairline was looking like lebron james
so this should be a huge reminder to you
guys to not wear your hair up super do
you believe this i do believe that so
you think this is real like it literally
don't wear your hair up or it'll make
you use your hair i don't know if you
can see my hairline but it's completely
uneven and because i've had to wear a
swim cap for most of my life for hours a
day and it would pull your hair back
so like your hairline seems pretty even
but mine is like
like pretty like jagged across and um
yeah i believe that of course that's
tension on your follicles like every day
why wouldn't it start to crawl backwards
i wish this was more of a known thing
like this is i'm blindsided
i'm like how does everyone not know this
and then
how does ariana grande always have her
hair up like that like that's so stupid
i think she fills it in it's called
traction alopecia yeah that's from
repeatedly pulling on your hair but if
you wear tight ponytails
carlos when you read
you do this voice
and it makes me uncomfortable wait what
is it tell me
do you not know
dude wait let's ask kalila now i don't i
don't notice oh she's so like
being nice that's not true so my voice
changes when i read i don't diss my
lovers
thank you you like turn into like you
you think you're teaching like a class
but you but you're that is all
projecting
that is all projecting you're thinking
about me too intensely
carlos will you read it to us again
but it's funny because the assignment i
have in this moment is to tell you
something from my computer so i am like
slightly trying to teach you something
that i'm learning one second before so
okay so that's and that makes you max
you don't trust him no no because i feel
like you're reading it for the first
time
but of course i'm reading about traction
alopecia
but like the way you're doing it is like
you're [ __ ] teaching us like you know
this and we should know it
go ahead try no that's the key word
should know i think you're preemptively
getting
it's like you're becoming insecure
no i'm not i
i promise you i'm not
should statements are very very
troublesome oh really yeah should it's
like they always tell you that in
therapy oh yeah like don't show yourself
you should and you got mansplained too
much and you're projecting that on to me
when i'm so not mansplaining you're not
oh i totally agree that you're not
mansplaining at all carlos how tight
were your buns
[Laughter]
or ponytails
i did notice my hair going away in uh
when i was 18 19. after not in 1819 when
i was 18.
[Laughter]
i wasn't explaining to do from wearing
hats and i would take them off and be
like i feel like my hair is going away
are you serious yeah so you did this
is a hat myth a real because i don't
believe in it i also think i was losing
it losing it at the same time yeah but i
don't think wearing hats all the time
helped me
but
guys wear hats right they do
i have a thing for this is very old
school it's the same way that i have a
kink for guys in timberlands because um
in high school yeah that was that's like
i when i smell curve right cologne or
guys with alcohol breath yes
grey sweatpants yeah totally boners
through gray sweatpants oh my god i've
never seen one but
i can show you today
also guys um with their hat backwards um
driving with one hand on the steering
wheel that's like a little too like to
me i'm like that feels like a kid that's
me every day
[Laughter]
say no you drive like this like
always like the middle that's so not
turning the wheel esther they have it's
not just driving straight forward it's
turning the wheel with their hat
backwards with one hand
not too much effort like they just know
well that was just a cartoon version no
one drives like this i do
i do too i'm 10 and two all day
that yeah no i know what you mean though
like okay but sorry keep going that's
all i had oh okay
yeah i um i still have a kink for these
um nostalgic things that i remember
liking when i was a teenager okay why
alcohol for me alcohol breath reminds me
this is like so
whatever but being in a frat being at a
frat party and like literally thinking
the boys were cute and none of them
being interested in me at all but like
remembering that they had alcohol breath
so it's basically what um
what does it remind you of being
rejected
no it just it's like oh like that's how
hot guys smell or something i like
alcohol breath because it in in the same
way bobby
used to
love me in the beginning sexually as if
when i would go out with my girlfriends
you know he doesn't drink he's not
alcoholic i think it's the same reason
you like it
um it's like this i come home a little
tipsy i smell like alcohol
he used to die for it yeah okay do you
know why i think it's the
he liked that um
you're like he's like naughty little
uh-huh exactly
and he would ask for blow jobs in the
car we would like make out in the car
and like
we would just do like teenage things he
was really into me when i
um was um unsteady and a little bit
drunk
it's almost like she embodies what i
cannot be
maybe that's what i have
maybe because you don't drink no i've
never drink i never want to drink i
but literally when i smell that on a
guy's breath i'm just like kiss me now
yeah no i hear ya i hate cigarettes i
hate the way a man smells when he wakes
up in the morning if he is a smoker but
if it's a fresh cigarette that he just
smoked and he comes to me and he talks
to me i will drop to my knees so [ __ ]
fast this is so bad we're admitting to
this but it's so real like why is it
naughty
naughty things
i i used to write not to
go back into my poetry
but there was this anything but that
um i one thing that i used to write or
not used to right one thing that i wrote
years ago
says he loved me when i
smelled of whiskey and when i defied and
i smelled the whiskey he left me the day
i baked him cookies
and i that is always a feeling like a
fear of mine that ultimately became a
reality oh my god i love that when i
became a safe harbor is when he was no
longer
like interested in that part of me what
the [ __ ] like now i'm literally like i
can never marry dave why because it's
like
it there's something to this like you
have to like stay slightly mysterious
and like [ __ ] slightly unreachable
yeah
you're probably know how to do that was
right but okay speaking of like being
into naughty things carlos i always
think of you like because you grew up in
like a very strict catholic school like
all boys
do you
basically like what i associate
catholics i know you had that too
catholic upbringing is like they make
everything so off-limits and so naughty
so are there things like that you're
super into because of catholic
upbringing
besides drugs
i would say
i feel like i was like into like strip
clubs and things like that
like nasty like
like just
like stanky girls or something like just
like escorts strip clubs things like
that i'm just like down with it and not
even like i imagine you like are similar
to me in a sense like i don't like
a big bougie strip club with only like a
talent i like the grimy grimy like the
strip clubs that i used to go to and
frequent
they're you know
like i think i thought it was the first
time i got like robbed and drugged what
was in mexico also the first time
you know when i did ketamine and i was
going down the hell hole i was like i've
been here before it's like why is this
so familiar and i think that's what i
was drugged with at a strip club one
time ketamine i don't know but it felt
almost exactly the same because i
remember like going back like i gotta go
to the hospital something's wrong with
me
and i was in mexico but i think that and
then my friend got robbed
and he was drunk too but we were at a
strip club when this happened all i'm
saying is that
the strip clubs that i go to
carlos would like them they would like
we have the same taste maybe
you guys i love liquid iv before i do
anything whether it's workout if i'm
going for a swim
before i go dive or even i'm just like
laying out in my backyard i always have
i always take a packet of liquid iv i
put it in 16 ounces of cold water and i
just feel so much more hydrated this
summer i'm really focusing on
like my mental health as you guys know
which means physical health which means
a lot of my anti-sadness walks a lot of
um that's probably all i really do but
like
i'm sweating more in the summer and i'm
also like paying attention to like what
color my pee is and like i just it's
really important for me to be hydrated
and it's a priority because when i'm
hydrated i feel better i look better
which is way more important
and liquid iv in six ounces of water
hydrates you two times faster and more
efficiently than water alone it is so
good for you you are getting your
essential vitamins your b3 b5 b6 even
vitamin c
um you are also getting three times more
electrolytes than any other sports drink
on the market liquid iv is non-gmo this
is the hydration multiplier i absolutely
love it i have been using this for so
long you know i get tired i'm talking
all day i'm talking all night i'm
talking in my sleep i'm talking i my
mouth open in my sleep i'm a mouth
breather if i forget to put my tape on
my mouth
i wake up with dry mouth i immediately
in the morning add the hydration
multiplier to my water
you guys can grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
percent off when you go to liquidity.com
and use code trash tuesday at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code trash tuesday at
liquidive.com
i love athletic greens i was just
cleaning my entire pantry out and i put
my athletic greens right out front
they're it's a it's something that
i'm putting on the counter um this is
how i start my day i before i eat before
i do anything else i take one scoop of
athletic greens i put it in cold water i
get my little mocha stir
and i take it down the hatch and it is
delicious it is um i i'm kind of
addicted to the flavor
i really like it i really like it i was
so surprised because when you whenever
you look at like a green substance
you're like this is gonna [ __ ] taste
like [ __ ] no i totally agree it
shockingly tastes good like i it's the
best tasting supplement i've ever tried
and you can go about your day now
thinking you've gotten all the necessary
uh high quality nutrients that your body
needs to you know
basically do everything just let
yourself win give yourself the morning
scoop to just win the rest of your day
with one delicious scoop of athletic
greens you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help start your day right and this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
and aging that's everything and also if
you are follow following a certain
lifestyle whether you eat keto paleo
vegan um dairy free or gluten free
athletic greens is all of those
uh it contains less than one gram of
sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals or
artificial anything while still tasting
pretty good you guys and you know what
tons of people take some kind of
multivitamin and it's important to
choose one with high quality ingredients
that your body will actually absorb and
so i like the fact that ag-1 just takes
the thought out of it for me i just rely
on them and i know they're sourcing
high-quality ingredients that i trust
and i'm getting them in right in that
daily scoop right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into the flu in cold
season it's just one scoop and a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your purchase all you
have to do is visit
athleticgreens.comtuesday
again that is
athleticgreens.com tuesday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
[Music]
i and tell me if it's like too
weird to ask you this now but i am
curious like how did you and bobby first
kiss but if you don't want to get into
it we don't have to um because obviously
our first kiss was
um
at my apartment um
and it was really fun it was like a
really fun makeout session a lot of
foreplay no sex
um we were just like
we were animals
we had so much fun
him and i
there's just so much like
like big big feelings like all around
and so yeah like it was very atypical it
wasn't like a you know tilt the head
and gaze into each other's eyes there
was nothing i would even say romantic
about it that's so
has anyone had that
but i would do this thing after that you
guys are not privy to
that i'm okay talking about now which
was i would do
you know at this time i was like peek
into um like hit training and um like
circuit training
so i would put circuits up for him and
so i would be like four pumps into my
[ __ ]
stand in the corner
um do this and then go on to the next
circuit and then come back here and then
put your dick in my mouth like it was
like a little circuit we used to do it
was like an obstacle erase for him
this isn't the sickest thing
i love it i'm so i don't know what to
say
carlos why do you love it
i just i like that it's creative it is
creative yeah japanese game show it is a
choice right open your mouth now let me
spit in it but each station
eats each station there's about eight
stations and each station
each station had a purpose this station
is for
you know doing what he liked to do like
an air guitar thing naked and he would
like twirl his dick had like air guitar
and he would do like a little air guitar
and then he'd move on to the next
station and then he'd go in his back and
i would spit right into his mouth so it
was like a
it was just it was so much fun
that is cool like
any thing where two people are just
being themselves freely
i can't judge yeah and and i think
that's why it was devastating when it
went away
what happened to our circuit training
you know i should have just like brought
out my whistle and you know like just
gotten him back in line
you know when i thought it was going
away i should have just blown a whistle
and be like get back over here no i four
push-ups
i it's like i don't even know how to
comment because i have no idea your
guys's situation is so confusing to me
like i don't even know well for starters
no one believes you're broken up okay
they're okay so you said it not me
like we've had so many guests on tiger
belly and everyone's like
yeah right
so you know
you know t
it's subjective yeah breakups are
subjective
it's really how you see them are they
together are they not who knows
and why does it matter why does it
matter there's there's 50 million ways
um a breakup can look and this is one of
them
okay i have a i have a i'm just going to
go you have hot guy in line for me
what do you have a hot guy in line for
me no but i have a theory
i'm like is this some kind of a sick
sexual
twisted game you're playing on all of us
that like
you guys are exes and then like it's
going to be hot to [ __ ] your ex like is
this all just to like build up
energy
yeah which of it is by the way love it
yeah i hope secretly that that's what it
is but
all good either way
um i want to leave that as a cliffhanger
we don't know we don't know okay you
know i'm i'm going to
just allow it to move the way it wants
to move okay yeah i think that's cool
sorry annie i have an out in 115 yeah
i'm just saving ourselves okay so
um
i want to ask you so bert and nikki and
a bunch of other comics were talking
about
when dudes um
like when two people are in front of
each other esther explain it yeah okay i
feel like we should show you the clip
it's about first kisses
let's let's show her the clip do you
remember ours esther
i don't know if i get it here
let's do headphones again
because we haven't actually played the
clip and i feel like i'm going to seem
like such a hater but
i found them
all right
the awkwardness of like the first move
that killing thing
just kissing like just making out i've
dated girls three four dates not kissed
them and then just was like i guess i'm
never gonna [ __ ] kiss i've never in
my life i'm so afraid of rejection i've
never my life gone on for an un joked
about at least kiss i'm real big on like
the is it stupid that we're not making
it out
like that yeah yeah i do the same thing
i always gotta make some jokes if i go
in if i would not survive i wish
emotionally a girl doing this
like turning the head away
he's never going to make a move and then
i would just go oh you know what i
wanted to tell you and they just like
casually and be like we should make out
but i've had guys be like
no i just don't feel it or like i have a
girlfriend like where you just are like
oh i just didn't need to do that and now
i have to like know you and see you at
this comedy festival the rest of the
world i still feel bad about that
well she she
um nikki said something there that
i personally would never put myself in
that position of not knowing um
whether or not a guy had a girlfriend or
not before i even offered to make out oh
i would never i would yes i would never
do that i would never yeah that is like
how was this a two-minute cut if you
have you mentioned how would you know
you just asked like do you just ask like
are you in a really that's one of the
first questions that's so embarrassing
to lean into a kiss of a boyfriend
you wouldn't want to cover those bases
but yeah that that base is covered i see
what you're saying you would need you're
right you would know i would get the lay
of the land before ever even considering
making out with somebody because i'd
never want to feel that rejection that's
true and i feel like if a guy
is someone that i'm attracted to my
first instinct is going to assume that
they have a girlfriend and that she's a
lot prettier than me and that if i try
to kiss him it's going to be
embarrassing but then you'll get closer
to the girlfriend you really want
stop pretending this guy is a boy no but
i feel like i've done that before where
i've been like do you want to make out
to someone who i actually didn't really
want to make out with but i was feeling
low about another guy
like if i make the move i'm in a dark
place already so it's like
yeah and he was like no you hooked up
with my roommate he goes you hooked up
with my roommate i was like three years
ago
i was like ew i got dibs yeah why why
does i'm mad at this guy well who cares
but i'm so glad he said no in retrospect
it's like i'll take that embarrassing
hit other than like having [ __ ] this
guy
that i would have to see um but nikki
also was saying so that means that's a
comedian she did that too
why don't you listen to their set and
see if they say they have a girlfriend
well what esther and i um agreed that we
didn't like is when dudes like are more
like passive aggressive like hey why
aren't we making out right now like that
i don't like that it's like i'd rather
guy be like i want to kiss you rather
than be like well shouldn't we be making
out just try it's just like yeah i feel
like i give and and i'm probably wrong
but i do feel like i give like
signs that it's okay but
i also probably don't but
what do you mean
well it's like i have had guys like do
you give like cute like you have to like
touch their knee you have to like let
them know you're into it
do you know what i mean like let them
know because they're so afraid of
getting rejected but also it's like do i
want to date someone that's that afraid
of getting rejected except todd was but
you know what todd was like scared to
kiss it was like todd was over my house
like four times and finally i was like
hello like i had to like tell his
friends to tell him to do it because if
i tell you if i become the girl like
nikki and whitney always bring up this
book called
getting to i do which oh yeah i mean
on title alone
uh
getting it
no thank you but but the thing in it is
all about like who's the masculine who's
the feminine like it doesn't always have
to be the girl or the boy but one person
has to be the girl and one person person
has to be the boy
listen i'm not being the [ __ ] boy in
this i dated a guy where i was like
you're being the girl
i'm the girl and he's like i'm the girl
like you're not the boy
but it's like you know i hate that sort
of
dynamic like i need the guy to make the
move or i'm not gonna have a good
relationship with him i don't know i
totally agree like it's so hot if you're
willing to be [ __ ] rejected you want
to kiss me so bad that you're willing to
humiliate yourself i'm like
that's hot
that is hot as opposed to being like i
wonder if we should be then i'm like do
you do you really even want to or is
this just about like if you think you
can or not yeah
but i'm like i'm okay with them doing
the joke i guess because at least that's
them making the move even though they're
trying to disguise it as a joke but i
had i'm telling you i was at a comedy
festival this guy for the entire
festival he was following me around he
was showing me to my shows he was so hot
and this is when i had low self-esteem
so i was like this hot guy is not trying
to hook up with me right like i only
date fat disgusting guys and not that
that's disgusting but the ones i dated
were
um
and like so i
i couldn't tell but i was like there i'm
not making the [ __ ] why he was trying
to make me make the move like we were we
would stand on like he stood on stairs
down the stairs so we were at the exact
same level and he was like so is my last
night here
and i'm like oh he's like i'm going up
to my hotel room and i was like okay oh
my god
and he was like so you know and then we
never hooked up but it's like
why was he that is so he followed around
he was like there's a sandwich he would
text me like when after he'd go to his
hotel yeah and he'd be like i'm taking
you up for sandwiches like call me when
you wake up after you shower all the
stuff like i would watch him at the in
the bar of the festival looking around
for me and stuff and i'm like i'm
getting all the signs but why do you
need me
to lean in because i've had guys that do
that and then they're not into they just
like the attention of it and want to
know that you will hook up with them but
i'm not
that is the worst case to me a guy that
they just want to know that they can get
you is so a red flag
it's like
why leave us alone
leave us alone together let us be
that is weird wait so what ended up
happening nothing he nothing
and then like i tried i was like i hit
him up to hang out in new york when we
got back and he wasn't and he was hot
like you were into him but he wouldn't
make the first move so it's just like
we're not it's not happening yeah that
is that's that yeah it's stalemate
because he wasn't like he didn't want to
hang out with me when we got back to new
york so i knew like oh you're not like
you're looking for just a hookup i don't
like to just hook up with people i work
with that's [ __ ] weird if you want to
like pursue me and try to date me like
i'll consider that but i'm not gonna
just
[ __ ] you and then have to see you
all the time and
you like have rejected you're just a guy
who rejected me and i'm at a show with
you
yeah
that's a little uh yeah i would hate
that
um i has anyone ever rejected you when
you try to kiss them no no never but
that's because it's not because
i was trying to think like i don't know
i think it's because of strategy i i was
telling esther earlier it's like i
read all the signs like i i don't i
would never put myself in a position
to like have to question whether or not
he's going to turn away but i have done
this to
a guy
a friend of mine who did go in for the
kiss and i did not want to obviously
kiss him because i was like you're a
friend and i did the weirdest thing and
i made a situation so much more awkward
this is when he came in to kiss me i
went i i veered right and i gave him a
hug and i i was like no no no no no oh
you babied him yeah and i was like oh no
no you burped him yeah i burped him
and it was he was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i was like it's okay it's okay i was
like no but no
and it just made it so weird after that
like we couldn't really be like normal
after that old annie would have just
that's why i drank so i could just like
oh [ __ ] you so i don't have to reject
you
whoops i forgot did i do that you know
what i am thinking about time i was
rejected not physically but like through
words
and this person i'll leave their gender
up to the audience imagination
said that is that what you're doing with
you too
with their whole look today
this person
said um
like i sort of like brought something up
like whatever it was and then they said
i oh i like you too much to put you
through dating me
oh
then they don't know you
we know you'd be putting them through
something
but like that is reminding me of like
the word version of like what you did
physically it's like no baby like yeah
that's still a cuddle i had a guy kiss
my shoulder once
what
okay did you just shoulder his mouth it
was no okay so we i had gone on this
camper union i did our shapira show and
talked about it i had a camp counselor i
had a crush on
my whole life i know but mine was not
okay mine as a kid was so cool he played
like dave matthews man songs on his
guitar he hacky sacked he was like
awesome
and i like had loved camp so much you
know like i just like idolized camp i
always thought about campus being so
great and then um
you know life moved moved on with my
quaker camp um i was doing comedy in new
york i just broke it up with a boyfriend
i run into one of my other camp
counselors and he recognized me like i
didn't think anyone from my camp like
remembered me like i thought i was like
a dork at camp and he was like oh my god
annie letterman
it's me mike you're like camp counselor
and was like oh my god mike what's going
on he's like oh i'm getting married next
week all of the
all the counselors are gonna be there
was like oh all of them he's like yeah
it's so weird you're doing this he's
like i follow you on
on facebook this was before instagram
was really that big and he was like um
me and one of the other counselors were
talking about how like you turned out
pretty hot
and i was like which one and he said the
one i had a crush on and i was like oh
my god i've like that's like my guy and
he's like well why don't you crash my
wedding and hook up with him so i went
like i was so excited i told everyone
about him like i'm gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of this guy
this is a guy i haven't seen since he
was 16. i was 14 and he was 16. i for
some reason thought he was still gonna
be hot even though this counselor like
looked like an old man like i was like
just thought
i don't know what in my head i was like
finally like this is it and i go fly
back or i take a train back to philly my
dad picks me up my dad drops me off at a
i'm literally like dad i'm gonna hook up
with my counselor shut up i swear to god
what was your dad saying my dad was like
this is you know good for you
you're like you know living a childhood
you know my dad's cool but
so oh
so he drives me like and it's like all
in the sticks and stuff we're going
through the woods to get to this bed and
breakfast and stuff were you just really
just right i was ready i mean i had i
didn't even bring a suitcase i brought i
didn't know where i was sleeping i had
one dress
i had a two pairs of underwear like you
know what i mean i was like i was like
this is happening you can stop it i
didn't know where i was sleeping i had
no clue i mean most of my life honestly
esther until the show
i had no clue
um so i
i'm getting there and it hasn't occurred
to me that this could backfire like it's
only gonna win like this is the only
the only shot is that this is perfect
and i live my childhood dreams and
everything's amazing
until i get there and as i'm getting out
my it's all through the sticks right and
it's getting dark and my dad goes hey i
just want to let you know like my night
vision's bad like i can't come pick you
up like if this doesn't work out you're
stuck here and i went why wouldn't it
work out i'm like as he's driving i'm
like wouldn't work out he's like bye
honey like why wouldn't it work out
my dad just showed me an hour and a half
to go [ __ ] some dude
and he's telling you he can't come get
you later and he's like just heads up
well night blindness is a real thing my
sister has it she's just like past a
certain time no rides like highways he's
fine like yeah it was too rural
like he can't handle like a [ __ ]
animal jumping in front of a car you
know it's just me like dad i'm
bottomless my dress is hyped up
he hits me that was the end
but so
i um i'm like huh and right as he says
that i'm like and i have this like
sinking dread and i go in
and
everyone
that wedding has already happened
because i'm crashing right but everyone
knows i'm coming i had written on like
the
the counselor page or whatever i found
they're like that you were gonna [ __ ]
him yes
everyone knew i was calling him a kill
for counselor i'd like to [ __ ] i didn't
and all of his facebook pictures he was
covering his face like i'll show you
pictures of him after this like it was
it was comedic like it was like you
couldn't see him it was like blurry so i
just is that the equivalent of upward
angle yes because i was like he's so hot
like he's so hot he doesn't even need to
like show his face
um
never that's never the case so i get
there
and everyone's like oh like i'm the
second most eventful thing happening at
the wedding oh lucky i'm like i like
stayed in the limelight i look cute
and i go outside
he's just
so little his wrists are like your size
mary kate olsen like he's like yeah he's
the he's the fourth olsen
i was like what have i done
i mean he may as well have still been in
jenko jeans like i was like um
so there was just no no chemistry but i
am only there to [ __ ] there's no
other thing you don't have it well yeah
are you [ __ ] i don't have a choice i
have nowhere to sleep nothing so all i
do is i go like i'm like well maybe i
can i love how this seems like this is
gonna be a story about how i rejected
him it's another guy after this i
rejected by the way oh i [ __ ] him but
um
so but i was trying so hard not to and i
was like the only angle i have because i
don't drink so i couldn't drink him hot
or do anything like that like i just had
to i was like i'm gonna just get him
really drunk so he passes out
so i kept like being like drink drink
and i'm like talking to everyone else
and
and um
he and there was another guy that i
another counselor that i didn't remember
but he was like into sports and stuff
and he was like masculine and he was
talking to me and i was like
okay this is the counselor i want right
so i was like i'm gonna vibe with him
so i can hook up with someone i'm
actually attracted to and then he can't
deny our chemistry he's going to have to
just go
so i'm like vibing with this guy i'm
vibing with him vibing with him he's the
groom
[Laughter]
no i before i lean in i find out
but so then um we're vibing and
everything and then we're all like kind
of like wandering around this guy i'm
trying to get drunk he goes i go he
takes a pill and i go what are you
taking and he goes
adderall and i'm like what he's like
yeah i just want to be able to stay up
and hang out with you and i'm like
so he's countering the alcohol without
it all i'm like are you [ __ ] kidding
me and then he's not going down any time
he walks me out he walks me on a like
over a bridge over this lake and i'm
like standing there with him like oh
and then i'm like where is the other guy
i'm like i gotta go find this other guy
i don't remember the guy's name and i'm
looking for him i can't find i can't
find him he's in the bathroom with this
girl that showed up to the wedding in
tevas he picked the team a [ __ ] over me
okay there was a girl in tivo's i was
like are we at home you guys are back in
fully though they weren't then they
weren't then but this girl had like a
mustache and listen we all have
mustaches it's all good i love that she
was actually like comfortable to just
grow her mustache out yeah she did
deserve the better guy yeah but so he
was stuck up with her so i was trapped
and then i found out the counselor that
i came to [ __ ] didn't have a room he was
sleeping on a pullout couch in someone
else's room so i had to like bang him in
the living room oh god i had a bang i'm
dead sober i'm like
kept the dress on
and it was a disaster and but it was
fine
[Music]
you know you may have started to see
these strange tall boys of beer in the
bottled water section of your local
stores and you may be thinking
i know three slugs that drink those
every night of their lives listen to the
sound
is there anything better
there's three new sparkling flavors
we've got mango chainsaw severed lime
over with kalila and bury it alive this
one is so good i know lime is my
favorite and the color
you guys were obsessed with liquid death
um annie may be a little bit more
obsessed than us but you know she comes
in here every day and she just chugs it
like a freaking champion because
death to plastic water and aluminum is
where it's at we don't stop on trash
tuesday we are liquid death drinking
slugs we are going to throw up yeah oh
my god even just
don't leave me hanging
but honestly that's the perfect analogy
of why i like liquid death i get to feel
bad while i'm doing something good
because i'm so addicted to doing like a
bad thing yeah and i have nothing left
to do
i have nothing left but water but
delicious water you got an aluminum can
you can get free shipping on all water
and merch at liquid death dot com slash
trash that's liquid death dot com slash
trash and that is a really big
opportunity because you can get it for
free shipping and
you can also support our show or you can
also find liquid death at 7-eleven
target albertson safeway or amazon but
we say go to liquidate.com and guys keep
up tagging us in your pictures of liquid
death we love that when you do that
[Music]
so he drives me home he drives me back
to the hot guy
yeah right who i think is hot because
i'm blinded by the fact that i've just
made this disgusting i've soiled myself
my whole childhood is over my favorite
memories of childhood are ruined
and so
he drives me back and we're and i'm like
telling him about like going to montreal
comedy festival i'm like yeah i'm really
doing well and stuff and he's kind of
like not saying anything like oh my god
he doesn't even like my job he doesn't
respect me this is so cool
i'm just like building him up into this
thing i'm like i feel like he was like
not that i'm like you know my my
attached anxiety
you know i was like oh i'll now i'll get
him to like me i just like i put so much
on this guy i projected so much on him
like he's so cool he's not sure about me
yet or whatever
so then um i book a show in philly
afterwards like i write him this whole
like inside joke thing on facebook i'm
like hey you know i come back to philly
all the time like i'm i actually have a
show next weekend and this whole thing
and i think he's like not into me and
he's like i'm gonna have to like woo him
i see him do the dot dot dot dot dot
yeah
and then stop dot dot and then stop and
like he's like thinking about and then i
went oh my god he's been into me the
whole time
and it like wasn't hot do you know what
i mean like he was like trying really
hard to impress me with the thing right
right right he was really really trying
to be careful about what he would yeah
he wanted to say something so then
so he meets me at this show what did he
end up saying
yes
or whatever so then
he meets me at the show
and i'm like oh he's a dork too he just
was less of a dork than the other guy
right do you know what i mean like i had
projected all my i was like this will
save my childhood memories of camp
so he takes me to his house and it's
just like
it's i'm like how am i at this guy's
house i'm trying to like get out of it
i'm not into him i've already
both of these guys i'm always like we're
gonna [ __ ] you know
so we're like on his balcony and i'm
just like you know i'm very stiff i'm
looking out in the city i'm like oh wow
it's pretty the lights
and then i just feel a kiss on my
shoulder and i go oh my god i go um
oh that might be worse i go the worst
thing i've ever heard oh my dad's
my dad's waiting for me
and i gave him one little make out and i
was like i'm so sorry my dad is waiting
up for me i gotta go he's no longer
night blind he's here to pick up he is
outside i gotta go and i just dipped and
i never talked to any of them again
shoulder kiss is just sending from
behind down my spine we were looking he
was standing next to me and we were
looking out he had like this really like
sweet spot like this sweet like
apartment so we're standing there and
i'm like just looking out at the city
and i can feel him here and i'm you know
i just ever so slightly kind of tilt
away from like i was just doing
everything i could to kind of just give
the energy and the vibe that
it wasn't going to happen
you mean your neck was crazy like i was
like this city is beautiful
and so i got my shoulder that was such a
long story no that was
amazing i'm
banana break
i have a follow-up question which is
like
was there
[Music]
i think the the thing here is that she
you just built uh like when you're
younger and something is a core memory
it it's a very big thing in your mind
and you really hang on to those like
like i told you the reason why i like
dudes with backward hats driving with
one hand or turning the steering wheel
timberlands whatever right it's like
it's just we hang on to these tiny
things and we build it up in our head
and with time they don't become smaller
memories they become bigger like they're
almost like you magnify especially at
the possibility that she could finally
hook up with this guy
i've been thinking about making this all
the time i was like this whole time i
thought i was a loser and nobody knew
who i was
um but i a shorter version of that story
sort of happened to me um when i um had
to leave um cebu and we finally were
going to immigrate to america um it
wasn't uh
it wasn't me walking to the gate to my
um flight and being like all right bye
they had to physically drag me through
the [ __ ] airport i was crying and
mostly i've seen you do that to esther
before
[Laughter]
partially because i number one i was
like i can't leave my animals i'm gonna
miss my dogs you had to leave your dogs
yeah i mean what was i supposed to do we
didn't have any money i wasn't gonna
like you know pay for a carrier we
didn't have a place this makes so much
sense why you have so many dogs you're
trying to replace yeah all the draggy
legs i left back home can only imagine
the dog that you left there but the
second reason was because i was in love
with a boy named james and james i had a
crush on him for a whole year previous
to leaving um the philippines but a week
before i left we finally had a moment to
like make out and he told me he liked me
and it was this whole thing and i'm like
oh i'm only here for six more days like
what's gonna happen i'm never coming
back to the philippines
and so i got dragged through the airport
crying because i was like james you know
i really
as soon as i got to the gate i put coins
into a payphone i called them and i said
you know i'm gonna miss you i'm never
gonna forget about you i love you and
maybe when we're older you know i'll see
you again in love he was like the only
um black guy in in my island basically
and he
and i was like filipinos named james his
name was i don't want to say his full
name because
but he was you know he his dad was black
his mom was like filipino
super hot i don't want to be weird but
hot super hot and he was always very
quiet and kind of like mysterious i
really liked him
and um fast forward a couple years i'm
now four years into my teenage life in
america and on my senior year i threw a
motel party with my best friends we got
it for like 45 dollars a night we steal
a whole bunch of alcohol from vons we
everything like we just walk out with it
we put it all in a tub with ice
and earlier that day i had a friend say
hey do you know that james is in america
now and he lives in the inland empire
and i was like
what i could not believe it all of a
sudden like my whole body like you was
like flooded with this is meant to me
this is my death this is my destiny like
he found me he didn't just land in
kansas he's in los angeles
this is going to
be like a love story
that this is the love story i've been
waiting for right you just fantasize
these things in your head
and i get super [ __ ]
drunk before he arrives he confirms that
he's coming he comes about an hour and a
half after we start drinking so i'm a
little tipsy already but no amount of
alcohol could prepare me for the fact
that not only was i not attracted to him
i was like repulsed like i took five
steps back when i opened the door he was
like hey it's me
and i was like my body was like no
no
and i um it
was quite possibly the most
disappointing feeling i'd ever had
because you just hang on to that thing
like i love james i love james
but no like
we need shirts that say i love james
and but i was still really nice about it
and whatnot but it just wasn't it didn't
matter you weren't as nice as me
i didn't [ __ ] him should i have [ __ ]
him
no he came all this way no no no no i
did not learn that lesson until very
recently where you're like oh you can
just say like no and choose yourself
over someone else
and it's not even that he was ugly yeah
he was like a good he was still good
with my people they were all cool still
it's just they were not my not what you
had in mind no it was not the boy that i
had like just i was like transfixed over
like i was i i had an image in my mind
of who he was and he had grown up and he
was someone completely different and i
was like stranger danger i don't know
you you're not james have you ever um
gone on an internet date what's an
interview oh wait you did with bobby
right you did yeah tinder okay my first
and only this i always feel i went on
two oh really yeah interesting because
i've only gone on two as well or yeah
two internet dates i've done so even
though you said one i know i said as
well
a little bit but so um
i there was a guy i met on bumble
and i in my head
when i saw his picture i attached
like a
like he was he said he was a music
producer so i thought he liked it hip
hop and stuff i was like i was seeing
him in a flat brim hat like i was seeing
him like
he was gonna be this dude or whatever
and so we like you know talked i never
heard his voice or anything we like were
talking i was like i'm so into this guy
i'd like just broken my boyfriend i'm
like i can't wait to [ __ ] you like i
just went all in i didn't know how like
i forgot that like when you meet people
there's no vibe you don't smell right
or whatever i was going off this picture
and i was attaching like so much of like
what i was looking for onto the sky
and so i created this guy in my head
this character of a person
and then when i met him
it was another like hey girl where i'm
like why are you
even looking for girls on bumble like
you just why are your wrists so loose
it's like this is you're not hot like
this is not like you're not for me and
he was he was a classical music producer
i went to his apartment he had his bike
hanging on the wall and he may as well
been wearing his helmet like he was like
he had dry cashews it was like i was
just looking at him it was like just dry
like bulk cashews sitting there was just
like he was a [ __ ] loser i was like
oh so i let him eat me out
yes
i know you always have to that's like
honestly that i would have done with
james if it was just
i in no i don't know
girls listen
at the most let them eat you out yes but
i feel like i feel like now i'm like
i've learned how to say no and that was
like such low self-worth to be like
i have to now appease this random person
i met on a
and um his penis was not that that
matters his penis was so small he like
pulled his dick out and i was like i'm
not gonna [ __ ] you just heads up i don't
know you or whatever and he was like oh
and he thought it was because his dick
was small i'm like no no your life is a
small dick sir i don't know what to say
like but i was trying i don't want to be
me it's not his fault that i but then so
now i'm in a situation where i have to
mourn the loss like i was so sad
afterwards because this character i
created doesn't exist i'd have like a
funeral for like
the hot guy that he hated yes
and i was getting eaten out at his
funeral by a guy with a
cashews with a cashew i definitely i
feel like when i was in i can't middle
school or high school had an experience
where like you talk to a guy on the
phone
and their voice it's like you're super
into that and then the in-person reveal
is like how is this yes how is this the
same and it's because you and your head
make it up
how you want it to be also there have
been guys where
i was like not really into them but like
things were happening and i was like
okay you can go down on me like yeah
yeah
but i think that's very like i can
[Laughter]
i like those like safe transactional
sort of like sexual things yeah it's
like look it's not fully there we both
know it's not fully there but let's
might as well while we're here you don't
feel gross now i have no no no because i
had a friend collab over here
i disagree because i had one like that
where it was the transaction was so
gross like it felt like
my okay it felt like my parents when
they were when i was a kid they ordered
the better sex videos from the back of
playboy do you know what i'm talking
about no they had ads for it in the back
yeah look it up carlos and it's like it
was like old regular people like
teaching you cunnilingus is this like it
was like a how-to sex tape which
actually i would love to watch now yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'd love to watch that but
like maybe we should watch it at home
and then report yeah but
but it like reminded me it like it is
like tran like i'm trying to t like i
don't know it just felt like that but i
okay so
um
a friend of mine for my quaker youth
retreats
um look at this i mean they actually
look better looking than i remember them
looking they looked like old it was like
a lot of short-haired women this is
making me feel bad for those that came
before us because they just did not have
good resources the way we have now just
double penetration yeah isn't it a thing
though that we have all these resources
but people are still pretty horrible but
sometimes it's that [ __ ] you because
have you ever [ __ ] someone that's like
their moves are so like movie that
you're like ew yeah you like practice
this like
what what you just said it's like when
someone feels like they learned it
it's a little well there's no connect
you're not like
with them they're like doing a thing and
you're like
but so okay so my friend from quaker
youth retreats he um i met him like
right after i got my nipples pierced but
um
i had like sort of been friends with him
for 20 years kind of like i hadn't we
were friends when we were teenagers i
used to go visit him we'd go like
snowmobiling and spelunking and [ __ ] and
uh
in the the woods in pennsylvania and
stuff but like i hadn't talked to him in
my adult life really and he
hit me up and was like in town and
or like invited me to go hang out with
him in vermont and i went to go hang out
with him and it's not that he wasn't
attractive or anything but it just was
like
we're friends you know and we're hanging
out and he was like started making out
with me and i was staying over his house
so i can't understand that with his
parents and stuff and we were in the
snow and stuff so it was kind of fun
vacation
and he's like should we [ __ ] and this is
when i was starting to like get my own
agency and i was like you know what i'm
not going to just [ __ ] everyone
that asks to be nice to them you know
like i actually want to have some
self-respect so i was like i don't know
if we should do it
you know like i don't i think it'll like
ruin our friendship and he's like come
on he's like i haven't talked to you in
20 years like what are we gonna ruin
he pretty much said that so then we
[ __ ] but it was so like it wasn't like
bad sex but it was just like using
someone else to come
it felt weird that's a good way of
putting it yes you know like it's like i
could rub my [ __ ] on a chair well now
why not just like jerk off at home yeah
it was weird and then
and then it continued on like we went it
just was like so weird and then i never
wanted to talk to him again because i
grossed myself out doing that right and
he was like writing me love letters and
stuff and i was like i told you this was
gonna happen because i told him i was
like there's a chance i'm gonna hate you
after this yeah and i hate him and he
still tries to hit me up every once in a
while
i had a love a story with a cockroach
exterminator that's similar that's your
dream guy he is my dream guy are you
kidding me he's doing the lord's work
for you literally he was like um i was
like well what college did you go to
ucla i was like okay i was like what do
you do for a living he's like oh i'm a
cockroach exterminator what like soon it
was like can you have that job when
you're in college that's the weirdest
like college job yeah
but he was very attractive i met him at
mountain bar in downtown l.a when
mountain bar was still a thing and then
um
i found him super attractive i was like
this guy's so [ __ ] hot he's tall this
and that but then when we went on our
first date we made out and nothing i
felt nothing not not a tingle in my body
not a single sensation overcame me and
but i was honest with him and before we
left i was like hey i was like i think
you're a great guy and honestly like
dream job like but like i don't think
there's any chemistry between us but
like can we stay friends and he was like
oh there wasn't he's like there was a
lot for me
and over the years
did he have a tattoo of your name
but he was just such a dope guy like
over the years we stayed friends but
every
year and a half or so i would be like
god he is so hot why don't i feel
anything for him so i'd be like hey
um you want to try again and we would
every year and a half we would try again
and then finally the last time he was
like kala like
like
why don't you just see how like i [ __ ]
oh right
now that's hot yeah i just literally i'm
soaking up here and so that's so hard
and so he was like all right i'll be
right over i was living i'll be right
over long beach at this time i was like
yeah okay i was like we're friends like
you know we trust each other how happy
would you know if kalyan said i'll be
right over here
i would be the one to say that i think
we know
you already are there sitting outside
our house idol
so this is the fifth time in a span of
five years and we were just like all
right
so
um he comes over and we make out on the
couch and i pull back and i'm like it's
just not there dude i'm so sorry like i
cannot like
keep going i was like i just don't think
we can get there and he was like [ __ ]
lyla jesus christ he's like this is you
can't keep going like this i'm like yeah
you're right every time i i had a
breakup he wouldn't be the person i want
to try with again and it just wasn't
there but i love this person like i
think he's a great guy he has a amazing
partner now but i always look at that as
like you cannot force what isn't there
you simply cannot i can't believe the
story doesn't end with us learning how
he [ __ ] i am so mad right now i'm so
proud of you and i wish i had learned
that and i feel like i want people to
learn from my mistakes and do not like
but if you do [ __ ] someone to be nice to
them it's okay you couldn't live through
it but i always was just like i'll just
like i just didn't like
hurting people's feelings like that yeah
and but you have to do that because it's
like otherwise you're hurting your own
feelings i mean i like
what if that was the guy that gave me
herpes or something i [ __ ] him because
i was like didn't wanna you know and
he's here with herpes [ __ ] me you
know not that herpes is okay i just
don't have it yet we're pro herpes as
well we're pro herpes yeah as long as
there's content with um you know
transmission that yeah i have herpes can
we [ __ ] and then you know yeah
exactly we're okay with the herbs yeah
um i wanna end this episode with um
um
this game
it's not really a game but
i want to know what the last song you
played on your playlist was and i want
you to read the lyrics to me
and i wanna maybe
um get into
why that song
was played why you like that song and
your state of mind today okay are you
sure yeah
i want to know i i hope to god esther
pulls up judas priest that's mike
i hope it's something completely
unexpected mine is never going to be
unexpected when it comes to music
of course it's lana del rey the song
ride
which is one of the lyrics okay
here here it goes annie pick a stanza
oh we're going to read
um i hear the birds on the summer breeze
oh you're embarrassing me i drive fast i
am alone at midnight
embarrassing faster
been trying hard not to get into trouble
but i've got a war in my mind that is
one of my favorite lyrics so i just ride
just ride i just ride i just ride
i love this song so much i love lana
it wasn't judas priest like i had hoped
but we'll take lana but i love like
when i don't know what i'm in the mood
to listen to it means you put on lana
like
it's it's soft it's soothing but it's
dramatic and like it just
it covers all the bases i don't know
yeah especially i was in vegas like it
has a very
you when you yeah how good is wise guys
isn't that such a good thing it was so
much fun the staff's the best yeah it
was so i like the purple lighting did
you get video
i don't think i did i don't know
i don't think next time
it looks cute with the purple background
the last song that you gotta go because
i gotta fake this one because this other
one's gonna make me seem crazy oh
[Music]
the last song that was playing that was
blaring in my car bef when i got here
was um i'll never love this way again by
dion warwick
i love dion warwick me too you'll never
get to heaven if you break mine
that's a different song but um
and
the lyrics are really um
oh this is very dark oh no i know i'll
never love this way again so i keep
holding on before the good is gone
i know i'll never love this way again
hold on hold on hold on
a fool will lose tomorrow reaching back
for yesterday
reaching back for bobby's [ __ ] like what
is this about bobby a fool will lose
tomorrow or is this about james
james
maybe this is about james and not bobby
carlos what's on your head
oh this is just a starface it's frozen
is that better than the zit
that's better than the zit
are you [ __ ] kidding me i do take it
off when i go downstairs to air juan to
pick up food oh because you respect
arawan better than more than us that's
what that means well i mean it's not a
respect thing it's more like i feel like
i can be myself around y'all that's
shocking you do
yes then now's the time tell us
annie it's your it's all right i'll give
you the one i was listening to oh my
gosh
j-rock win
j-rock
win okay
pick a let's pick one
win win win win yeah
stop thinking about our show [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] on 10 10. i don't want you
to have to read this
bring friends friend friend friends
there's something there's parts of it
you can't really say you might want to
keep score
i win win win win squad
tattoos
squad squad squad all right third album
coming soon
hey i ain't chasing after no [ __ ]
i got bigger plans than staying rich wow
that is a good i love you yes
i mean blasting it
i've never heard
is it like hard rock
no don't apply it real quick
and we can just take it out
yeah what is like the is it it's so good
i like this part cls for baby mama
mercedes
oh my god he gets the mercedes reference
so he likes it
wait what is the one song you have to
listen to before like you know you
either have a big meeting or something
like you're hiring a roar no honestly i
agree that's a really really important
one for me important
it's important also i'll throw on a
rascal flats life is a highway
oh
i love rascal flatts
what about you do you have one stormzy
audacity is like my number one like hype
song if i need to get into like i got
this i got it did you listen to it on
the way in today no i listened to dion
warwick i was like freaking you know
i'll never love this way again
also jail off of donda the kanye song
jail is so good well i don't know if
i've told you guys this before this is
like an embarrassing thing i used to do
when i was in like when i was trying to
build my confidence i was like a drunk
scooter driver and when i was like in
santa fe just like this chubby
jager and jizz filled waitress
driving around in my on my motor scooter
all drunk in santa fe
i um that song alicia keys
no one uh but i would make the lyrics
about me like where it was like me to
myself yeah um
instead of like no one will get in the
way of what like what i'm feeling for
myself yes i like that when i first got
broken up with i chose i would listen to
the song lovely day by bill withers and
i made it about me like just one look at
you
in the mirror i was like that's me
um also i've been listening to a lot of
dolly parton
like her i'll always love you is like
the best the very best it's the most
loving
you know that was about when her and her
um
her writing partner broke up
she wrote that song for him and she sang
it to him and they were able to like
move forward i listened to a whole
book on each of dolly parton's songs and
like what about her life inspired her to
write them it's so cool holy [ __ ] no one
is better than dolly it was so beautiful
and
and she sung that to him and she said
that he like just cried and like
understood her point of view and stuff
her song code of many colors
gets me in just
i'm a puddle of tears i'm trying to
remember what that was so we all got
breast implants since we like dolly
well maybe can we make her get pressed
again for us i've been doing a joke
about breast implants i don't want to
say it on here but bring your fake
titties to the show
well you guys thank you so much for
being sluggies
and we'll see you next week is that it
yeah yeah i think so bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
you